Well, on that note, let me try and thoroughly explain this.
This one is such a beast too.
Oh my gosh.
Good luck, Joel.
Yeah.
I don't know if I fully understand this one to be honest.
We should have taken bets in advance.
Like, all right, how many out of, how many, so we each have five, right?
How many out of five are we going to be able to successfully get a passing grade on?
So I think, I think I'm going to start this one off with a song, Joel.
Oh no.
We're going to get copyright strike.
It's the most wonderful time of the year.
It's the top 10 web hacking techniques of 2023 by port Swigger research episode.
Oh yeah.
It's going to be a good one.
I'm really excited.
Yeah, dude.
It is going to be a good one, but let me say I am.
Well, for before, before I talk about myself, where are you right now?
So, cause you look like you're in a dungeon.
I basically am.
I'm in, in my parents' basement.
Unfinished basement.
Yeah.
This house is like 250 years old.
Oh my gosh.
It's, it's like old school basement.
Wow, dude.
But yeah, I, I drove from California to the East Coast to, I guess I'll, should I say?
No, just, just, you can leave that out.
I'll just say East Coast.
Yeah.
But yeah, I'm moving into a new house.
We're closing soon.
And yeah, it's pretty exciting.
Nice, man.
Super pumped.
Well, I saw the Zillow listing for your house.
It looks awesome.
And soon you'll be not in a dungeon, but in a mansion.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well, a mansion is a, you know, just like contrast, contrastarily.
They're going to think I'm, I'm loaded with bounties.
It's all from that, you know, critical thinking money is what it is.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I got mansion money.
We're just, we're just loaded from doing this podcast.
Oh man.
Cool.
Well, yeah.
Like you said, dude, it's going to be one hack of an episode.
Essentially what we tried to do last year and what we're going to attempt to do again this
year is cover all of the top 10 web hacking techniques of 2023, which Port Swigger releases.
They do sort of like a competition every year and you know, the community votes on the top
hacking techniques.
And all of these are amazing pieces of research and are extremely technically dense.
Yeah.
And so for the past, I don't know, it's probably taken me 10 hours or so to read through everything
and fully understand and prepare a document and that sort of thing.
Yeah.
And, and, and so we're going to try to condense it down to pretty much what you need to know,
the tricks and tips and you know, assuming a base level knowledge of, you know, hacking
techniques, what is, what are the things about these specific pieces of research that stand out?
And we'll try to condense that into, into one episode.
Do you think we can do it Joel?
I don't know.
Oh, we're going to, we're going to try, you know, this, uh, yeah, I was reading through
some of these and, uh, they are really, really deep reads.
Um, so yeah, even if we explain it well, I think, uh, everybody should still probably go
read them all individually.
Yeah.
Disclaimer, we are going to skip number two.
.NET serialization.
What, what is it called?
Exploding hardened .NET deserialization.
Cause it is a 124 page white paper that Justin said read this document.
He was like, Hey, uh, can you just like read through these and make sure that they're like summarized.
And so I, I picked the first one that's assigned to me and I open it up and it's a GitHub link
to a PDF.
And I was like, Oh, you know, this, uh, this looks good.
And I downloaded it and I opened it up and it's page one of 124.
And I was like, I sent him a picture.
I was like, did you know that this is 124 page white paper?
And he was like, wait, seriously.
I did not know that.
So, you know, we're, we're going to skip that one, but I think, you know, the rest of them,
we should be able to speak to fairly well.
Um, so let's, let's get into it, man.
First stop is number one.
We're going to start from number one this year.
Did we start from number 10 last year?
I feel like we did.
I don't know, but I'm going to do it in whatever order it's in the doc,
which I think is the same order that's on the, the post.
Yeah, they are.
This is the, the placing order.
So number one, and it was kind of funny if you actually click the link to, to go and look at the actual.
Portsweger research, you know, the top 10 web hacking techniques of 2023 research.
There's like a description for each one of them.
And number one, obviously James is the one that kind of puts this on James Kettle.
And then he said, you know, his one number one, uh, as, as it should, because it's amazing research.
And so he says in the beginning of the description for that, he says, well, this is awkward.
I always knew that there was a risk of rating research when I also published it myself.
And after seven years, it finally happened.
I now have to declare that my own research is the best.
James, we all knew your research was the best.
Your research has always been the best.
That wasn't really a question.
No, really, uh, kind of crazy.
Um, but yeah, so he released some research this year.
James did James Kettle and he releases research every year.
And I always make a habit.
I always make a habit of trying to read it as soon as possible.
Um, because oftentimes he's highlighting systemic issues that can be exploited in lots of different environments.
Um, and so I always make a habit of reading this right off the bat.
So I've, I've read through this multiple times before.
Now this is my, my third or fourth time through it.
Um, and this is a particularly simple, to be perfectly honest, uh, exploit that, that James kind of came out with this year.
It, it takes some, uh, pieces of research from two different researchers and some of his own research from the past, uh, combines it together with some features of HTTP2 and creates this super awesome technique, which is like now the go-to technique for, um, for race conditioning, uh, testing in the browser or in the, uh, in web applications.
Um, have you, have you seen it?
Joel, have you read through this whole thing?
Joel Kettleman Well, yeah.
So interestingly, this research is actually used in another one of the top 10, um,
Oh really?
Joel Kettleman Yeah.
So, uh, so I'll, I'll let you cover it cause I think it'll make the net, the other bug make a little more sense.
Joel Kettleman I, I, I didn't get to chance to read through all of the ones that you, that you're, that we assigned to you.
Um, so I'm interested to hearing about it too, but essentially to summarize this research, um, James figured out a way to abuse Nagel's algorithm, uh, which is a,
sort of like a TCP algorithm that, uh, is used in to optimize TCP packets being sent.
Um, so that there isn't like a bunch of TCP metadata and then like one byte of data, um, in conjunction with HTTP two, uh, in conjunction with the last byte sync, um, sort of idea that he had from a couple of years back on getting, um, race conditions to align.
Joel Kettleman And essentially the, the new thing is he utilizes HTTP two, which can send multiple, um, uh, sort of HTTP requests stream together, um, in a single TCP packet.
Um, and then essentially he only, he used in one TCP packet, he uses, he puts the last byte in some times the, um, the, the last byte in the end stream, uh, frame for the HTTP two sort of structure, um, in the same TCP packets.
Joel Kettleman And then send those all at once.
Joel Kettleman And that will complete all of those HTTP requests all at once.
Joel Kettleman And essentially get your, uh, hit times for these requests down to sub one millisecond, uh, allowing for very effective race conditions to be achieved.
Joel Kettleman Amazing technique.
Absolutely mind boggling.
Super, super interesting.
Uh, I misspoke.
Joel Kettleman This is a different piece of albino wax research.
Joel Kettleman Oh, really?
Joel Kettleman Yeah, no.
So, uh, yeah, we'll, I'll, I'll explain, uh, my other one, uh, when I get to there, but yeah, no, this is, uh, I mean, one of the things that I really love about James's research is that he approaches things from like a fundamental level, right?
Joel Kettleman He's like, for a long time, he was looking at like, you know, HTTP smuggling and desyncing and all that kind of stuff and like attacking like the layer, what is it, layer three, layer four, um, the, you know, um, level, you know, HTTP servers and all that kind of stuff.
Joel Kettleman And then, uh, now he's, he's at like TCP layer, which is like, so, so close to like, I mean, next, the next, uh, albino wax, uh, you know, research is going to be plugging in an ether.
Joel Kettleman He's going to be like, and that's the Mac address level.
No, um, I do like that, how he approaches it from a holistic perspective.
And I also think that this specific writeup, so the concept is pretty, pretty simple, you know, group the last bite for a bunch of HTTP requests into one TCP packet, um, you know, with all this data being sent over HTTP two.
So that's really cool.
Um, and in the writeup, he does a really, a really good job of making the algorithm seem really simple.
And he actually condenses it down to just a couple bullet points.
So I'm just going to read it, uh, word for word here.
He says, um, excuse me.
First, pre-send the bulk of each request.
If the request has no body, send all the headers and don't set the end stream flag.
Sorry, flag.
I said frame, but it's flag and withhold an empty data frame with end stream set.
If the request has a body, so that, that, that was, was, there's no body.
Then send the headers and all the body except the final bite withhold a data frame containing the final bite.
Okay.
Um, so that's all you've got to do.
It's really easy to implement in, in various, uh, different libraries as well.
So this is something that I really, really like Kaido to implement.
Um, or once we get a, uh, sort of plugin extensibility piece of Kaido, uh, I will really be looking forward to using this because I know burp has a feature now where you can group a bunch of tabs in repeater into a group.
And then you can right click and hit send in parallel and it will actually use the single packet methodology to send all of those together and synchronize them.
And I just think that's such a beautiful, simple way to do race conditioning.
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Maybe I, maybe, maybe this is somewhat related then because the, uh, the, the, I'll talk about this book now.
Are you, are you, uh,
Yeah, that's, that's about it for this one.
I mean, just the, the takeaways for this one, I just want to highlight again.
Is understanding, you know, this, how it works right with the HGP two and, um, sort of including only that last bite as well as the end stream, um, fly as well.
And then also just being able to do this in burp, right.
Um, with, with the, uh, send in parallel, those are the main sort of takeaways for this one and allow you to also getting down to one, one millisecond sort of time, which would really, really make.
And this is also no network jitter affects this because it's all hitting the server at the same time, which is, uh, just revolutionary.
So yeah, that's my, I've said my piece now.
Where did you want to go with that next Joel?
Okay. So what I was going to say is, um, you know, so this next book also, this is a number two.
Sorry.
Oh my God.
So we're going to jump around.
Okay. What number is this?
I know.
Well, number two was, uh, the 124 page white paper.
Okay. Okay. Okay.
Okay.
.net serialization.
So, um, uh, I will jump around.
I'm going to jump to number eight, which is the, from Akamai to F5 to H to Ntlm with love.
Um, now this is a really, really cool bug.
Um, it's, uh, it's one of those bugs that you read through and you're like, wow, this sounds almost too simple to be true.
Um, because essentially it is like textbook HTTP request smuggling.
Um, they, they were just doing a normal pen test.
They were, you know, looking at this target at the end of their test, they ran an HTTP, HTTP smuggler scan through burp.
And, uh, it came back with a bunch of findings.
I'm like, Oh, that's kind of weird.
Uh, you know, the, it looks like the trace method is, uh, is being like processed by this backend server.
Um, and there were a lot of references to Akamai and Akamai.
Uh, Akamai edge servers.
Mm.
And so he did a bunch more testing and he noticed that indeed you, there was, you know, a specific gadget that he was able to put together that you could, um, put HTTP request smuggling through the Akamai edge directly, like directly attacking the Akamai edge itself, instead of like the customer servers underneath.
But you would have the ability to attack, you know, other proxies and stuff.
Right.
Um, because there are so many different possibilities, he initially found like right away, 25% of the global caches could be poisoned through cash.
Oh my gosh.
Directly through the HTTP smuggling.
So HTTP request smuggling into the Akamai edge servers.
And then from there you can smuggle whatever you want.
You can poison the cache of internal servers, the Akamai cache, all that kind of stuff.
Uh, but then he also realized like, Oh, well, I mean, big IP by F5, this is vulnerable to, uh, you know, cache poisoning as well.
A lot of people use big, big IP, especially behind Akamai.
So he started scanning for, through, uh, Akamai using his vulnerability to find other big IP servers.
And sure enough, like, you know, three quarters of the big IP servers were also vulnerable to cache poisoning.
Oh my gosh, dude.
So he's going through, he's farming, he's submitting a bunch of reports.
He's getting three, 4,000, you know, per report.
He's got like 20, 30, then he's like, he's looking through his call, his callbacks and he's like, huh?
What is this like weird off callback?
And he realizes that there's this like, NTLM off over HTTP thing that exists for like Office 365 and a bunch of other things.
And, uh, as it turns out, you can also use that to steal NTLM hashes.
So he was able to, through the Akamai edge into big, F5 big IP, poison the NTLM cache to get NTLM tokens back and, you know, full off takeover, you know, full arbitrary redirects through cache poisoning.
Um, oh my gosh.
Yeah.
I'm looking at this at the end here.
Absolutely insane.
They just got like a bunch of NTLM hashes just pouring in via, via responder.
He he's using the catch him.
It looks like.
Wow.
I wonder, I wonder why.
Oh, this is interesting here.
So what, why were they reaching out to off in the first place?
Something super weird is going on here with Microsoft stuff.
Yeah.
I have a feeling it's because of the like weird redirect stuff that he was testing out where he realized that he would, because he could cache poison.
He could basically arbitrarily redirect people from whatever to wherever.
So bank SSO or, you know, customer logins or like anything you could put them anywhere.
And so I think he was just redirecting a bunch of stuff and started to notice, uh, that, you know, that he was getting these, uh, these Microsoft, uh, logins.
Dude, request modeling is such a crazy vulnerability.
Cause you just start seeing traffic from other people's like sessions and stuff like that.
And yeah, I hadn't even thought about, um, sort of, uh, putting that together with like any sort of NTLM based off because yeah, there are mechanisms for that in Microsoft environment.
That is really cool, man.
What a, what a cool write up.
Yeah.
And it really depends on the org and, and you know, how they set it up.
Right.
But yeah, I mean, this was such a, such a cool, and I liked how he was able to scale it, you know, like that.
I find that's kind of challenging, uh, for me, like when I find something, I usually rely on somebody else to help scale it, but being able to sort of like identify that this is a widespread issue and scale yourself is a, is pretty awesome.
Yeah, dude, that's sick.
I'm definitely going to go back and redo this one a little bit more.
I feel like HTTP request muggling is like one of those things that there are a couple people that are really good at it and, and that like it shows up almost every live hacking event still too.
You know, somebody gets like some massive crit from HTTP request muggling and it's not like the normal, the normal, like big crit players normally.
Uh, it's like these people that are really good specifically at request muggling.
So I think that's one of the things that I need to sit down and sort of deep dive over the next, I don't know, a couple months and try to try to understand that a little bit better.
I found it a couple of times, but mostly just relying on burp and its scanner to tell me when, Hey, there might be something funky going on here.
Yeah.
Same.
I feel like it's one of those things I've exploited maybe like a handful of times, but I'd like to get a lot better at it.
Yeah.
Alrighty.
Let's, uh, let's jump to, to number, I guess.
So that was number eight.
All right, Joel.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Thanks for that, Joel.
Now I'm gonna, I'm gonna have to go ahead and, uh, I'm gonna have to go in here and
We'll go back into order a little bit.
Straight.
Okay.
I'm gonna talk, you strike through number eight and number one on our list so that I know which ones we've actually done.
Um, and I'll jump down.
So like we mentioned, we're skipping number two dot nint serialization, uh, cause it's, it's very long and we didn't have time to prep it.
Um, and we're gonna jump right to SMTP smuggling.
Okay.
And I thought this writeup was, was very funny.
Uh, it's number three in, in top web hacking techniques of 2023.
Um, and, and there's a, a quote from this, uh, uh, uh, writeup that says literally quote, since this blog post is about SMT smuggling and doesn't have anything to do with web applications.
Um, like why is this in the 2023 top web hacking techniques if it doesn't even have anything to do with web applications, which is true.
It doesn't.
Um, so the, the rest of the writeup proceeded to explain a bunch of, uh, SMTP, um, security mechanisms.
And it does a really good job of, uh, like starting from zero, um, because a lot of people that are reading this early for me as web hacker, aren't familiar with the SMTP protocol super in depth.
So they give a nice summary of, uh, SPF, which is, um, essentially in place to validate what IP addresses and domains are allowed to send mail for a certain domain.
They, they talk about DKIM, um, which is, uh, providing a signature for the body.
So it isn't tampered also validated over TXT record, um, by DNS and then also DMARC and DMARC is the one that's really doing a lot of the heavy lifting here because, um, SMTP, uh, protocol has two sort of from fields, right?
There's the mail from field, which is sort of a part of the SMTP metadata or the, the commands that are being sent to the SMTP server when data is being transmitted.
And then there's like the message data from field, which is like a different from field.
So often something that a technique that's used to spoof is having the mail from being different from the actual message data from, um, and DMARC sort of solves that issue by comparing SPF D D K I M and the from, um, in the actual body of the message, um, to ensure alignment and that sort of thing.
Um, and, and this technique, so it's called SMTP smuggling.
And the reason for that is the guy sort of took inspiration from James Kettle's, uh, HTTP smuggling research and said, Hey, how can I apply some of these things to SMTP?
Um, and the, the sort of data end indicator in SMTP is, uh, normally slash r slash n dot slash r slash n, right?
So he's like, okay, I wonder what we can do to kind of work around that.
Um, and so eventually what he ends up doing is finding that some servers will accept slash n dot slash n, um, or slash r dot slash r, um, as the terminator for a specific message, right?
Um, a piece of message data.
Interesting.
And he can use that difference along with some, um, I guess binary data encoding stuff on some servers, um, to essentially create a mismatch between the relaying SMTP server.
Um, the, the one that's sending the message, the one that the SPF record points to and the SMTP server that receives the message.
Um, and because you know, all, all of this authentication is happening on the other side of this.
Um, you know, you're, you're essentially taking advantage of a mismatch between the relaying server, which is allowed to send mail for like something like outlook.com, right?
Some, some big, um, uh, domain, uh, you know, that input is trusted.
Um, so I went, when I was looking at it, it's kind of reminded me of a, of sort of a mix of SSRF because it's taking advantage of what that server's authority is, right?
Yeah.
In that server's position as a trusted entity to send mail, um, and HTTP request muggling, um, to send mail from pretty much any domain, uh, which is, which was totally bad-ass, but not necessarily related to web hacking.
Yeah, not quite web hacking.
Right.
But that, I mean, now I'm thinking like, you know, here we are linking NTLM hashes over HTTP.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's true.
You know, maybe, maybe it is possible somehow, some way, uh, maybe there's some, some proxy server that will allow you to send to SMTP or something.
Yeah.
So, so, so sort of big takeaways for this one, uh, kind of understanding and applying HTTP smuggling methodology.
Where does the data part of the transmission stop and how can I get a mismatch between two different entities on that?
Um, that's one big thing.
Um, and I also just really like the, the, um, concept of applying HTTP vulnerabilities to different protocols that might have similar functionality.
Um, so I'm sure that there's other protocols out there that could benefit from HTTP smuggling-esque, uh, sort of vulnerabilities.
Uh, and I, I think we could definitely see some cool research coming out like that in the future.
Yeah.
You know, it, it makes me think, especially like how, what this looks like, uh, on like code analysis side, cause that's, I feel like that's one aspect that I haven't really seen covered.
Like a lot of this seems to be very, very black box approach.
Like almost like there's some weird magic that goes on when I send all these requests in a certain way and it just kind of works this way.
Mm-hmm .
But I'm more curious, like why, like, why does it work that way?
Yeah.
Like where, you know, and is this like a pattern?
I love it.
It's almost like the balance between like a CTF and code golf where.
Yeah.
Like it seems so simple and you're like, okay, something, there's gotta be some weird functionality
here.
And I, I, I love thinking about problems in that way, even if it's not a CTF problem,
!
Cause it really makes you think creatively about like, okay, let's imagine this is vulnerable.
How, how, you know, what, what are the mechanisms?
What is, what's every single lever I can pull and let me go through every single one
and figure out what I can exploit.
Yeah.
And I'm, I'm looking right now at this exploitation video.
I just kind of got like nerds and it's fast too.
It's not, it's not particularly slow.
You know, I thought it'd be like, you know, try like 160 requests or whatever for one, you
know, bite, but it's, it's pretty fast too, which is very impressive.
Um, wow.
What a piece of research, man.
Dude, you got so many of the, you got so many cool ones.
Now I gotta, I'm sure they're all cool.
You know, I, I gotta go and read them all.
Um, but that, that one's definitely, I'm going to go back and reread that one.
Um, although I probably should probably go back and reread it next time I've got an LFI
because I'm definitely not going to remember any of that shit the next time that I'm thinking
about, uh, WordPress faults, especially.
Yeah.
And, um, and the impact.
I've had an LFI on WordPress stuff in the past, um, you know, year for sure.
Um, actually in the past three months, but I think actually something interesting is going
on with PHP eight, I believe PHP eight doesn't allow you to do that PHP scheme anymore for
like a certain number of calls.
Like I want to say like F stat based calls, I think so like file exists and that sort of
thing, um, or stat based calls.
Um, so that's something to look up as well.
All right, man.
Number four on the list done.
We're making progress.
We're pushing through.
Um, next one on the list is HTTP parser inconsistencies.
And I actually super loved this research.
I've tweeted about this research before.
Um, you know, it got put on the list here, but, uh, this is such a great example of just
like really quality, high quality Lee conducted research.
What am I trying to say?
Uh, the quality of this research is very high in the way that they've conducted it.
Um, and there's a, a bunch of different, um, backends that essentially they've compared
with how Nginx in particular, uh, parses routes and they provided vulnerable configuration specifically
based off of the trim or strip functionality associated with these languages.
So essentially what kind of characters like a new line character, like, you know, white space characters,
uh, non-displayed characters, that sort of thing.
Can you append at the end or at some spot in a route that will make it, um, uh, not match a, a Nginx rule or match an Nginx rule and still match a route on the, on the backside.
So let's say you've got sort of like a, a, a, a blacklist on the front end for, um, you know, Nginx and you, you want to access an admin route on the backend.
So that's the whole scenario they set up here.
They set up like, just like a slash admin route or whatever that just says admin.
And it said, and they've got an Nginx route on the front end that just says deny admin.
Um, and then they get access to that by adding, um, these various characters.
So I'll just kind of read through these really quickly.
Um, to give you guys an idea for the various languages.
Um, and hopefully you'll go and document these yourself so that you, you know, when you see the various server headers, uh, pertaining to these various technologies,
you'll understand, uh, what kind of inconsistencies could be in place with Nginx in those backends.
So, um, first up was, uh, was Node.js and there is a bypass.
There are many bypasses for Node.js when it comes to Nginx, um, reverse proxy sort of, um, um, I guess blocking or, uh, blocking a specific route.
Um, the, the, the one that works in the most versions is the backslash X AO, uh, character.
Um, so that, that code point, uh, and that works in versions 1.16 through 1.22.
Um, and, but there's also other ones such as the, uh, hex 0.9 and OC characters that get stripped out by, um, Node's trim function.
And does, they don't get stripped out by Nginx on the front end.
So Nginx assumes it's a different route.
Whereas Node understands that it's, that once it's trimmed, this is actually just the slash admin route.
Yeah.
And I just, I'll interrupt for a second.
I just love this aspect of hacking where it's like, so often when you're testing these types of things, you're putting like dot, dot slashes or percent 0 a or backslash n,
but you're not actually trying the character itself.
And this is, this is like the, the cool step where it's like an actual, you know, like X, a zero.
Yeah.
Like the, you know, this weird hidden, like non printable character that is getting sent through and parsed weirdly.
Yeah, no, it is really good stuff.
And it's odd to me, and I haven't taken the time to dive deep and understand why each one of these specific characters is a part of the various languages, um, you know, trim or strip.
Uh, functionalities.
Uh, but it's kind of odd that this is so hard.
Like, why can't we just say, okay, white space is a space and a tab and a new line, you know?
And the answer to that is because there's so much variance in the specs and, and stuff like that.
But, um, it's just something that seems like it shouldn't be that hard, but is actually very hard.
And that margin is where we live, Joel.
That margin is, uh, is where we make our money.
Exactly.
So, uh, cool takeaways for this one, you know, make sure you're trying all of these, uh, sort of hexadecimal code points, which obviously correlate to various ASCII characters.
Um, I guess maybe not be within the ASCII range.
Uh, but these are all very cool to, to try out.
And essentially what we need to be able to do is identify, Hey, there's Nginx plus some backend where the incompatibility is there.
Um, so the, the ones that they've talked about here are nodes, specific node versions, Flask, Spring Boot, um, PHP.
Uh, and I think that was it.
And they also talked about some stuff with, um, with AWS, uh, WAF in particular, which was super weird.
Okay.
Uh, so I'll, I'll deviate from that whole, um, strip and trim, uh, functionality there to bypass, uh, various Nginx, uh, block blocking rules.
And actually talk about this, this other sort of like extra that they kind of threw into this writeup, which is essentially like apparently some backends parse line folding in headers as a thing.
So essentially you have an HTTP header, right?
So X colon, blah, blah, blah, blah, slash R slash N.
And then if the next line starts with a tab character, then it assumes that, that, that is a continuation of the previous line.
And is, is actually a part of the, uh, character that's above it.
So in the writeup, they actually found a way to bypass, uh, the, um, uh, Amazon WAF, uh, using this.
Uh, but I just thought that that was a weird thing to actually have some languages parse.
Like why are we line wrapping HTTP headers at the protocol level?
Like what is going on here?
It's so weird.
And, um, you know, I will say it sort of as an overall arching theme across the, uh,
across these top 10, I don't recall if it was pulled out as sort of a conclusion within the article itself.
But what I've noticed a lot is it's a lot of like parsing bugs lately where these are like, these aren't anything like, it's not like we're even talking about new protocols or anything.
Right.
We're talking about HTTP, we're talking about, um, you know, SMTP, sure.
Again, old protocol, but it's not like protobuf or, or, or some new technology or anything that's causing this.
These are all like existing product or existing protocols and technologies that are very widely used, but just have some fundamental issues depending on the implementation.
Um, and a lot of it also reminds me of the orange research that we talked about, um, not too long ago about legendary stuff.
Yeah.
The HTTP parser stuff and the engine X, um, you know, parser bugs with semi colons and dot, dot slashes and all that kind of stuff.
There's, there's, there's always going to be those sort of bugs.
And it kind of goes back to what we were talking about last week, which is like context, understanding the context is king in, in all of these scenarios really, because almost all of web vulnerabilities, uh, I'm sure there's cut and dry access controls and stuff like that.
But almost all web vulnerabilities originate from some sort of misunderstanding or, um, misconstruing of context and what data is to be interpreted in what context.
Um, or assumptions.
Yeah.
Or assumptions on that.
Exactly.
Um, and so let me see, I think, I thought there was one more little takeaway from this one that I wanted to mention.
Oh yeah.
The other cool thing that they kind of mentioned within this research as well was various backends have a different way of parsing.
Um, the, so, you know, when you do an HTTP request, it's like get or post or whatever, and then the space and then normally slash, and then it provides the path, right?
Um, some backends parse that path piece differently when the first character is not a, a slash.
So some people will allow some, some people, some backends will allow you to put an at sign there, which is super helpful for SSRF in some scenarios.
Um, some will allow you to put a, a semi-colon there.
Some will allow you to put a, and that's often in the, um, in sort of like the spring environments where matrix parameters are a thing.
Um, and then some, uh, I want to say the, was it PHP environment?
For some reason, we'll just let you put a, an asterisk there, which is real weird.
Like I don't even know, they didn't even mention in there why they let you put an asterisk there, but this is something to fuzz for sure.
But another thing that I've seen is, uh, you can put full HTTP URLs as well.
Um, that's for proxy syntax, I think by default, but, uh, 0.9, I think syntax.
Yeah. Yeah. Something like that.
But it also will work in like, you know, other HTTP versions.
So it all depends on the implementation and what they choose to support.
It's super, super weird.
Backwards compatibility.
Another thing that, uh, makes us our living.
All right.
Um, that's all I had for.
This one, uh, you want to go ahead and take the next one or, or maybe we can tag team that one since we, uh, we didn't get fully through that one.
Yeah.
So this one, this one was from, uh, Kaspersky researcher, Sergey Bobrov.
Um, he's a, he's a really talented, um, researcher and he gave this presentation at, uh, off, uh, off zone 2023.
Um, and it's basically talking about these HTTP requests, uh, splitting vulnerabilities.
And it, it all stems from these, uh, engine X misconfigurations, right?
Uh, just like orange research, just like, um, you know, many other pieces of research.
It's very easy to misconfigure things, uh, without realizing it's misconfiguration simply just by like trying to use, you know, oh, I'm going to write this config out.
You, and you put an extra character or something, or you copy paste it and you didn't really know what it did.
So you just left it in.
You make chat GPT write it.
Yeah, exactly.
And it's like, here you go.
This will work in all cases.
Um, and so it's, it's super, super interesting.
There's, um, you know, the root of it is basically, uh, this, uh, this regex, right?
That's looking for, uh, a slash, uh, instead of just allowing all characters to go through.
So, so yeah, I, I, I brought it, broke a couple things out here into the doc Joel for this one.
And, and that regex piece I think requires a little bit, uh, nuance here.
So essentially what, what's crazy with this is, is maybe, maybe we'll, we'll put this up on the screen for those of you that are on YouTube.
Uh, put on screen, please.
Put that one up.
Um, but essentially there's, there's this regex when you're defining a location in Nginx Roros proxy container.
And if you use it, when I looked at this, it's just so weird.
So if you use dot star, then that's the safe configuration, you know, for this, because it's not going to allow you to inject.
It feels so backwards.
It does.
It's not going to let you inject like, um, apparently these line break characters that are going to make everything terrible.
But if you use an, a, um, I guess an exclusive range.
So if you say a square bracket and then the care upward carrot slash, and then close close brackets, you're saying, okay, allow every single character except for the slash.
And in that scenario, uh, that's a more permissive definition actually than the dot character, which is super weird and will allow you to inject new line characters and line breaks, which will allow you to just overwrite the whole request, which is nuts to me.
It's super interesting because I want to say that I can't remember if in, if in Reddx by default, the dot, it's supposed to include white space, but I don't know if it includes new lines.
That's interesting.
Unless you explicitly have the, uh, like multi-line flag on, right?
Yeah.
That's a good point.
That could be what it was.
But there's probably some weird implementation issue here because like you said, one is like an exclude, like an exclusive range where it's like any character that's not a slash versus any character that's a dot, which then gets translated into A through Z, like any character, maybe except new lines, um, or whatever.
So it's just like, it's, it's such a weird new, unlike, I mean, I would have never expected that those two things would be backwards.
And just to be clear here, what we're talking about is, is matching the location on an NGINX reverse proxy rule.
So this is the definition for what route you can hit and it will trigger a certain block of code.
Um, and inside of that, there's regex to allow for things like IDs and that sort of things to be included.
Um, so this is, this is really, uh, some, some cool research and it makes me wish that I had the NGINX configuration files for so many of these targets that I work on that use NGINX.
So it's like, man, I'm sure there's so many like weird edge cases out there that, um, that this could, could cause.
And, um, and, and the next one as well is, is a proxy pass based, um, uh, NGINX problem, which was actually originating from some, some research Frans did, of course, you know, years before everyone else started thinking about it in true blue Frans style.
Um, which most of you guys have seen likely where he was proxy, uh, doing a proxy pass to, uh, Amazon AWS and was able to override the host header.
And since the, the host is actually, um, you know, since the backend server is the same for all S3 buckets there, he could actually specify his own bucket as the host header.
It would get virtual routed to his bucket and he was allowed to host any arbitrary content on a website.
Um, so that those are the two sort of main techniques that they mentioned in there for like how this vulnerability could occur.
And the other thing that I thought was cool here, Joel, was the detection methods for this, that they sort of outlined because, um, I think this sort of bug is a little bit tricky to understand and a little bit tricky to find, um, without source code, because you're not able to look at the configuration file and say like, Hey, Oh, that's one of those like commonly known patterns that could result in HTTP request, uh, splitting.
Um, and so they mentioned a couple detection methods that could be helpful for this.
And the first one is simply visiting, you know, site.com slash, and then the path to whatever your, um, anticipated split.
Um, what am I trying to say there, Joel?
The, the, the place where you believe the split may be occurring, right?
Right. Right. Right. The intended delimiter.
Exactly. Um, and then actually just putting a space and an X there.
So the actual backend HTTP request that gets generated is get or whatever, slash the path space X space HTTP slash one dot one or whatever.
Right. And that will result in a 400 on the backend.
And hopefully that will bounce forward through the reverse proxy and show you a 400.
Um, the, uh, I'm sorry, that, that will give you a different error code.
That that's the differentiator that has to give you a different error code.
So if you put the space X in there, it needs to give you some error code.
That's not a 400.
Then if instead you put space.
H engine X by default, it looks at that and says, Oh, that starts with an H that's them specifying the HTTP protocol.
Right. So that's them saying that's the beginning of HTTP slash one dot one.
Right. Um, and then it will say, Hey, we're parsing the, we're parsing the, the protocol here now.
Oh, H is the protocol. That's weird. That's not a valid protocol.
Bam 400. Right.
So this is a, this is a good way to tell whether you're actually injecting into this sort of backend.
Um, you're injecting into the actual syntax of the HTTP request because space X should give you some other error code and space H because of that engine X sort of tendency should give you a 400.
Yeah. Yeah.
And then there's the, the one step further, right?
Mm-hmm .
And it should say, you know, bad protocol or something.
Exactly.
And that's for sure, for sure. Then you're, you've got CRL F injection.
Yeah. So, so the input there would be space HTTP slash one three dot three seven, of course.
And then the new line character. So we're completing that first line of the HTTP request. Right.
And then we'll, you know, add like an X header or something like that to catch the remainder of the original HTTP request.
And then when the reverse proxy tries to communicate with the backend server like that, the backend server is like, wait, what the heck?
I can't use HTTP 13.37. I don't know that protocol.
It takes back a five Oh five and five Oh five is a very rare error code. I've only, I don't think I've ever seen it actually.
Yeah. I've never seen it.
Yeah. Um, and so, um, if you're able to trigger a five Oh five, then you've certainly got request splitting.
So this could be great for any of you people out there that are doing mass scanning and want some high signal, um, like scans to do for, for HTTP request smuggling.
Yeah.
Just what I would do is actually, you know, run down or something like that. Take all of the paths that come out of gal.
And then at that sort of junction at that each path level, then put this, this payload in there and then look for detect off of five Oh fives.
And you should have a pretty high signal response for anything that, that could be vulnerable to HTTP request smuggling.
Yeah. Yeah, for sure. Super, super interesting. So I love those little detection methods, you know, those easy takeaways.
And then if you see something that's working, go back to that paper and then start to read a little bit deeper and then see how to exploit it.
Exactly, man. Oh man. The next one is so good. Kinugawa Masato-san. Thank you so much for this, for this write up.
Um, I feel like nobody better could have, could have gotten the summary for this one. So I'll let you go ahead.
No, it's, it's great. And, uh, I, so actually at the beginning of, uh, so number seven, well, before I get ahead of myself, let me talk about this.
What this actually is number seven is how I hacked Microsoft teams and got 150 K and pwn to own by a lot of people.
By, uh, Masato Kinugawa. Um, and essentially this write up was great. And in the beginning of it, he's like, Hey, you know, if you're interested about the non-technical experience that I had with bone to own, here's a couple of podcasts in Japanese for you.
So I've got those on my list. I'm going to like put it on like 0.75 speed and try to keep up with these guys in, in Japanese.
But, um, I was able to fully parse through the, um, amazing write up that he did. And wow, there are some great takeaways from this one.
Um, so essentially what's happening here is they're in an electron environment, uh, hacking Microsoft teams for pwn to own.
And, uh, essentially he gives us some cool takeaways on what to look for in an electron environment, pretty basic stuff stuff.
I've heard before, but still helpful to review. So, um, whenever the browser window object is instantiated in a, um, in an electron environment, um, there will be some parameters that can be passed into this.
Three parameters of interest in particular node integration, context isolation, and sandbox. Okay.
And so what this is going to do, take those one by one node, node integration.
If node integration is set to true, then if you get XSS on this target, um, this is the traditional thing you kind of always hear about when you, when you get XSS in an, in a electron application, then you should just be able to get RC.
Well, that's only true if node integration is set to true because then in that case, you could access the node, node JS APIs directly and do something like require and just run, you know, whatever code and exact your calculator or whatever.
But if this is set to false, then you don't have access to, um, the node API and you're not going to be able to, um, get RC as easily.
Unfortunately for, uh, uh, Masato, then the, in the scenario, this was actually set to false.
So he had to figure out some other way to get RC, even if he had XSS.
Um, the second one is, uh, this is the second parameter that you should be looking in, into and sort of the instantiation of the browser window object, which is core to the electron applications, um, is the context isolation sort of argument or Boolean here.
If, if this is set to false, then the context between, um, the client side JS and the JS that has access to node APIs, um, is not actually segmented.
Um, and, and because of that, what you can do is do prototype pollution.
And that's what he ended up doing later on in this, in this, um, write up is he overwrites the function.call, um, uh, definition prototype and was able to snag access to it.
It's a pretty good one though.
It's a folder. I'm not going to lie.
Um, and it was able to detect when the correct function was being passed in and get access to some stuff that he needed, um, which is really cool.
And the last one is sandbox false or true.
Um, that one is pretty clear for anyone who has ever worked with Chrome.
That's whether Chrome's going to be running in a sandbox.
Um, if this is set to false, then you've got a much easier time exploiting Chrome related bugs, um, inside of an electron application.
If it's set to true, then you've got to figure out how to escape the sandbox, even if you get like a Chrome based RCE.
Um, so cool.
So there's that, but dude, this isn't even the craziest part, Joel.
This is crazy, man.
Okay.
I mean, here I want to say, I'm thinking it was crazy.
It's good stuff.
I'm not even there yet.
Thank you for the information.
But you've got to see the way he gets X assess on this thing, man.
So, you know, he's, he's participating in Pwn2Own.
Pwn2Own is a no user interaction event.
So you've got a Pwn without anyone interacting with it essentially.
Yep.
And essentially what he found was that he could send a message to a user over Microsoft Teams.
And, um, he could specify some, you know, basic markdown tags, right?
Like bolding and stuff like that.
Yep.
And when you look at how that's implemented, you're able to implement a couple, you know,
HTML tags that are helpful.
And he, he found a, uh, a white list for, uh, class names that can be specified on these,
uh, you know, like the strong tag or whatever.
Right.
So now he's got like, okay, I can specify some, and one of those, those white lists had a star with it.
So it was like Swift dash, whatever.
Right.
So now he can specify any class name that starts with Swift dash, which is like, how could this possibly be helpful?
Like, and I just, I don't understand how, and Joel using that, using not even arbitrary class name injection, he gets XSS, which is just absolutely, absolutely inspiring.
Um, and, and, and it's really, um, a great reason to look deep and understand how this application, you know, how, how these applications are working in every single bit of every single inch you can take from the application might be able to be used in an exploit.
That's so awesome.
I mean, it, it's gotta be like the perfect stars aligning feeling where like he's looking through, he's like, oh, no way.
Like, oh, this exists.
Exactly.
So this is how he did it, Joel.
So, um, Angular is being used in this application, right?
On the front end.
Yep.
And there, if you could specify an arbitrary attribute in Angular, you could specify the ng init attribute, which would allow you to run some code.
Pretty standard stuff with Angular, um, uh, if you're familiar with it at all.
However, what I do not know is that the ng init attribute can also be specified by a class attribute, which is super weird.
Look, look at the, look at the screenshot in the doc, dude.
Look what he's got here.
He says any element ng init equals expression, right?
That's one we're familiar with.
Any element class equals ng dash init colon expression also allows you to just run arbitrary JS code inside of the class attribute for any freaking HTML tag.
That's so weird.
What?
Like, it makes, like, why?
Like, why does that work?
I don't know.
But it's, it makes no sense.
It's more contexts in which you can get XSS, which is really cool.
Um, so then he's able to use, you know, constructor dot constructor or whatever, the, the, one of the classic, um, ways to call arbitrary JS code.
Um, and, uh, get XSS.
So now he's got XSS from when, uh, from, you know, just sending a user a message and that now he's going to use the context isolation to get RC via that, which was an absolutely crazy part of this writeup and not particularly generally applicable to most environments.
So I won't go too deep into it, but essentially what he does is gets access to this object, um, called IPCU renderer.
And this is, uh, inter-process communication renderer.
And this allows you to communicate between the main process in, in, um, in, in electron application, which is a little bit more privileged and the renderer, uh, process.
Um, and essentially using that inter-process communication renderer object, he's able to communicate with a listener on that side of it's loaded up, that has a vulnerability in it and is able to pop RCE, um, and land that sweet, sweet pwn to own money.
Um, but biggest takeaways for me on this one, make sure an electron application, you're checking those three attributes, node integration, context, isolation, sandbox.
And then also what the heck, apparently you can get XSS via class name injection.
Who knew?
Yeah.
I mean, that is like the last thing I would have ever tried of all the, like, maybe if I was just broadly scanning for payloads and every attribute available on, on an element, maybe, but like, that's when you've truly given up.
The, the, the levels of desperation that we go to, um, to pop XSS, man.
Um, okay.
So Joel, you already covered Akamite F5.
Um, which was number eight, number nine.
I'll, I'll just kind of breeze through really quickly.
Um, and essentially this is cookie crumbles.
This is a long academic paper written in academic style with a bunch of like, you know, special notation where like, you know, why is this?
And it's like, why, why are we making this so complicated?
Um, but I read it and it was good.
And, uh, it had some cool, some cool techniques in it.
Um, some things that weren't quite as applicable, um, that they seem to be excited about, but I don't think has as much real world application.
But, um, I pulled the good bits out for you and I'm going to go ahead and tell you about them right now.
They tried to re they tried to rename C-Surf to, to Corf, which is a more accurate sort of representation of most of the, um, cross site.
Typical academics.
Forgeries.
I know.
Um, no, nothing against the people.
I mean, they wrote a great piece of research, but, um, that is the more specific name, cross origin request forgery.
So if you're one of those people that would like to be a little bit more specific with what they're talking about, um, uh, you know, I think you could use cross site request forgery and cross origin request forgery, um, to interchangeably.
To, to be able to specify the various nuances of these specific situations where you may be same site, but different origin.
Um, and you know, so there's some nuances with, with regards to that, regarding to same site cookies.
So that's one, one little thing.
A couple of the things they talked about stuff we've talked about on the pod before cookie tossing, um, which is essentially using, um, the path attribute of a specific cookie to override the value of a cookie that's already in place.
Um, we've talked about this before, but I'll just provide a little refresher cookies that are set.
So let's say you've got a cookie set gadget by an XSS or something like that.
You can make your cookie prioritized in the user's browser.
Um, if there's a cookie of the same name by specifying a more specific path, um, uh, otherwise it will default to which one was created first.
Um, so really helpful thing there.
It doesn't actually depend on which domain was specified in the cookie at all, which probably it should, but, um, uh, you probably should go by more specific domain.
But such as life, that path specificity piece is really helpful for, you know, overriding for doing session fixation and that sort of things.
Like, um, when you need to get your cookie prioritized over a cookie that may already be set in the victim's browser.
Take a breath and take a breather there.
Next one is cookie jar over.
That's 150 pages.
Dude, I mean, how, I mean, our notes from this episode is, what?
From this episode as well are like what eight pages long.
Uh, yeah, I don't even know.
I turned off the pages cause I didn't want to know.
It's nuts, man.
Um, and then the next thing that they talk about cookie jar overflowing, we talked about that.
I've got an app set up at apps.rinerator.dev that you can check out to see, you know, how many cookies you need to overflow your specific browser.
Normally it's about 180.
Um, and another cool takeaway is you can push out HTTP only cookies from the cookie jar with non-HTP only cookies.
So good to know.
Very interesting.
The novel attacks from this research, there were two.
Um, and these have also been mentioned by, uh, Ankur Sundara, whose, uh, write-up we mentioned and we'll link in the description.
Uh, we mentioned in the past.
Um, but essentially these attacks are surrounding nameless cookies and how you can set a cookie that doesn't have a name.
And so it's set dash cookie colon equals something.
And the way that browsers handle that is really, really hecked up and servers don't know how to parse it and everybody's like screaming and it's, it's bad.
Um, and so if you think there's some sort of weird nuance you can do with that, uh, that's a functionality that you're, that you should be aware of.
Um, unfortunately, uh, most of the applications of this from an attacking perspective are overriding the underscore, underscore, host and underscore, underscore, secure prefixes to cookies, which are essentially just, um, like more secure versions of the cookie attributes, um, uh, secure and, uh,
setting the domain attribute.
Mm-hmm .
Um, so there's not a ton of, of, uh, application of these nameless cookies, but it's still some nice quirk to be aware of.
And, um, there's lots of, uh, sort of misconfigurations and misinterpretations of cookies.
Um, when those cookies names starts with an equal sign that they sort of documented in this paper.
Um, and, and, and I think that they also listed a bunch of cookies.
Um, listed a bunch of CVS that they found and got fixed in this paper, which.
Cool.
You know, cause we, you know, you may be able to bypass those or use them in an environment.
Um, that is like when you're dealing with that sort of older technology, but they're patched now.
So not a ton of super awesome takeaways from, from that, from like a, uh, sort of a methodology perspective.
Yeah.
Mm.
But I do love that little, uh, replacement.
Like, you know, it's just one of those gadgets you tuck in your back pocket and, uh, later when, when you need it.
And that one off chance, uh, it'll be there when you need it.
Exactly.
All right.
The next sort of novel attack that they sort of mentioned here, um, is various bypasses for underscore underscore host.
Like I mentioned before in, in a bunch of different server side parsing environments, PHP, we all know the thing.
Well, maybe we don't all know.
It's pretty well known that PHP replaces dots with underscores.
Um, and a couple other characters, I think as well, a dash is included with underscores when they're populating their, uh, infamous dollar sign underscore get under dollar sign underscore post dollar sign underscore cookie objects.
Um, so that caused some problems for essentially processing those cookies as well.
Um, so be on the lookout for those sorts of discrepancies.
Um, the last piece of helpful information from this, uh, write up or from this research that I was able to find was a pretty well-documented description of various C-Surf protections.
Um, they, they came there, there was a couple of far-fetched examples where they were like, you know, if you're able to like set a cookie and there's like pre-session fixation and like the generator for the C-Surf
token is linked to like the pre-session, not the actual session.
It's like, there's some really odd stuff, uh, in there.
Um, that, that didn't seem quite as applicable.
Um, then, you know, there, there were those, which was interesting, but the one that I thought was most helpful was they make a description of a common C-Surf framework, which I'm not sure we've actually talked about here on the pod, which is called the double submit pattern of C-Surf protection.
Okay.
And essentially what this is, is the, the application will set a, a cookie on the user session that says C-Surf token equals XYZ.
Right.
And then when you send a request, you have to send in the body C-Surf token equals XYZ.
And on the server side, it will compare the cookie that you sent and the cookie and the request body and make sure that those align.
And if it is, then it passed the C-Surf check.
Um, so this, I've seen this many times.
I've bypassed this many times.
If there's a way for you to fixate a session, a session, a C-Surf token and get your C-Surf token prioritized, right?
Using the path methodology that we mentioned before, you can fixate that token, you know, maybe using a subdomain, an excess has in a subdomain or something like that, and get your token prioritized and then, um, send that value as a C-Surf token parameter in your post request or whatever request to C-Surf.
Um, and that will result in a bypass of C-Surf protection.
So that was something that they documented really clearly that I don't think we've talked about before.
So I figured I'd, I'd mentioned that as well as the last piece of information, uh, in this cookie crumbles academic research analysis.
Thank you very much.
That was a man.
That was such a dense one.
It's, uh, it sucks because it's such awesome research, but it's, uh, it's very difficult to like, you know,
like get through it, you know, like if only these academics could figure out how to write blogs.
I know, man.
I know.
And you know, I, I, I hate, I hate to dislike it, to be honest, because they're doing us a great service and finding a bunch of really cool things.
But, um, yeah, it's so different reading blogs versus reading academic write-ups.
So, but maybe that's my own experience as well.
You know, maybe I just need to read more academic papers.
And somebody who's written a couple academic papers.
It's, uh, it's definitely a little song and dance, uh, to, to, you know, for the whole process and they could be simplified.
I think.
Sure is, man.
All right.
Last one on the list.
EPP server takeover by our boy, Sam Curry.
Um, let's go ahead and give a, a, um, analysis of this one.
Uh, we'll talk about it and, uh, close it out for this, for this episode.
Um, yeah, sure.
You want to go ahead and take it.
It's a pretty straightforward XXE, I think, but it's just the most crazy critical piece of environment ever.
Yeah, right.
It's like extremely, extremely safe, uh, straightforward.
So there's this whole protocol called EPP.
It runs on port 700 and it's an XML based protocol.
And literally like the most set, like open a socket on port 700, send the, like, a github.com textbook example of, uh, of an XTC payload.
And it's like full read of Etsy password.
You know what I, it's like, it's re it's really, really like the most simple XXE possible, which is kind of terrifying.
Uh, knowing that that is, you know, was running some core part of, you know, internet infrastructure for a very, very long time.
And it was just widely vulnerable, uh, for a very, very long time.
Uh, but it's just one of those great, great examples of, you know, don't take anything for granted.
Right.
Maybe that's the takeaway for this is like, even if it's a core technology, even if it's something that seems really straightforward, don't take that for granted.
It's probably vulnerable and you should, you should dig a little deeper.
Yeah.
Right.
Every single thing today is, but you know, like fundamental HGP, fundamental SMTP, fundamental EPP, all the P's.
Like, yeah, everything.
It's, uh, it's, it's, I mean, it's, it's mind boggling, uh, to think, uh, how many things I probably have looked over just because I'm like, ah, there's no way that's fine.
I'm not going to spend time on that.
I think the other really cool thing that they did here was actually understand the, the straight outside of the realm of web app security.
And they, they went into this, you know, odd protocol that's running on, on port 700.
And sometimes the dubs are there, you know?
Um, and, and so that's really, that's really impressive.
I think.
Um, and, and, and I just, this line cracks me up, man.
He said, you know, like you said, he like, it's the same, you know, leak Etsy password, uh, sort of default, uh, X, XE payload that you see from GitHub.
And he says, our proof of concept was extremely effective.
And it's great.
It was dude.
It was, it was amazing.
Um, and it just goes to show that, that, uh, there are weak spots and those weak spots are going to be the best spot to get in because they got control of how many, I mean, this is like 20 top level domains.
Um, yeah, from, from this.
And, um, the, the other thing that I'll say here is that notice how they, they pivoted, right?
You know, they didn't just, uh, take this X, XE.
They used it to grab some, some source code and parse out some Java that was running in there.
And then they found another LFI that allowed them to get access to Etsy shadow and somebody's private keys to actually log into the server, which is just so bad.
Which had backups of all the root zonas as well.
It's nuts too.
That how much of this, how much of this internet infrastructure that we all rely on every day is like just taped together with, you know, already owned stuff.
Yeah.
Absolutely nuts, man.
Well, on that lovely, uh, optimistic note.
Yeah.
On that, it's a wrap, right?
Anything else we got on, on this one?
I think that was about it.
We, we actually moved through this pretty quickly, probably because we skipped to the 124 page .NET deserialization white paper.
Yeah.
No kidding.
I, um, I mean, it's still a really, really interesting paper.
There's a bunch of CVs in that one as well.
And, um, I, uh, I'm for sure going to go circle back on that one and, and read through it a little more closely, especially when I'm testing on .NET stuff.
Absolutely.
Um, let, let me ask you this, Joel.
Let's, let's reorder them.
Okay.
We'll, we'll, we'll pull, we'll pull the, uh, the .NET deserialization one out cause we haven't, you know, done our, our due diligence on that one.
But if we were to go ahead and reorder this, where would you put it?
Hmm.
Okay.
I think I would put, I would leave the state machine at the top.
That one's the most widely impactful, I think.
Right?
Yeah.
That was really cool.
Fundamental like research in my opinion.
Hmm.
I think I would put the HTTP request splitting, the HTTP parser inconsistency and the Akamata F5.
Those are all very, very close to me.
I think I'd bundle them together somewhere together.
Maybe not, maybe like third place.
I think second.
Third through sixth place.
Yeah.
Third place.
Third through sixth.
Second place hacking Microsoft teams.
Really?
Uh, I think so.
Cause that's such, I mean, that's like, so crazy.
Uh, or mint.
No, sorry.
Second EPP.
Oh, I'm, I'm all out of order here now.
Okay.
First place stacking, smashing the stack.
Hold on, hold on.
What is it?
EPP.
I'm going to, I'm going to actually write down Joel's list here.
Okay.
So, smashing, smashing the state machine.
Stack, the stack, the state machine.
Not the, yeah.
There you go.
That one.
Yeah.
The state machine.
Okay.
EPP number two.
EPP.
Numbers three through six tied or tied for third.
Okay.
Uh, parser inconsistencies.
Parser inconsistencies.
Okay.
And, uh, Akamite at five.
Plus splitting Akamite at five.
And then.
Okay.
Hacking Microsoft teams.
Teams.
Okay.
Hacking Microsoft teams.
Teams.
Okay.
Then.
SMTP and cookie crumbling.
Filter chains.
I'm almost tempted to put that a little lower, but, uh, and then cookie crumbles and SMTP.
All right, dude.
So you said smashing the state machine EPP parser inconsistencies request splitting Akamite at five teams filter chains cookie crumbles SMTP smuggling.
This is a very different order than what I would do.
The only one probably that's similar is smashing the state.
Okay.
Uh, so I think I'm going to put mine at smashing the state machine at the top.
And the reason for that is that it's very elegant research.
The cons he explains it really well.
The concepts fairly simple.
The implementation is very clear and the implications are giant for an underserved vulnerability class.
Um, second for me, man, I don't know if, if the filter chain piece where you can just, um,
generate arbitrary content, like generate like, you know, question mark PHP, you know, run PHP info or exec or whatever.
If that's included, which I think is extremely applicable research, then I gotta put, I gotta put, um, filter chains at, at number two.
Yeah.
Filter chains is one of those, like, uh, when I'm looking at my list, it doesn't feel like number seven.
I think it's hard because I mean, it's somewhere in like three through three through three or four, I think.
Yeah.
Maybe I would put filter chains above the three parsing ones after the EPP server.
EPP server for me is like such a cool, like fundamental, like internet core, uh, infrastructure thing.
Um, that that is so, so crazy dangerous.
Um, and like so simple that it falls at number two for me.
But if it was like you needed to admin perms or something that would be higher on the list.
Yeah.
I'm seeing you type your list out.
So number one, you've got Smashing the State Machine.
Number two, filter chains, three teams, uh, four, quest splitting, five parser inconsistencies, six cookie crumbles, seven Akamai, which is interesting.
Why do you split the Akamai out from the other, uh, parser ones?
So I'm kind of doing it based off of, dude, your, your laptop did the thing where it's like, where it did the thumbs up thing again.
Did you see that?
Okay.
No way.
Because I'm not even using the external.
Oh, it's on.
I turned it off.
Oh my gosh.
What is that thing, dude?
It pops up every couple of videos.
It's this thing called the reactions and it's built into Mac.
Like, I don't know.
That's.
I thought it was only when I was using my phone as an external camera.
It's so weird.
So essentially what happens is he'll like do a, like a thumbs up on the screen or something like that.
And then like holding the mic like this and it's, and it'll parse it as a thumbs up and then it'll do like the thumbs up emoji on the screen.
I'm like, why are you doing that?
Um, hopefully it's now all for good, man.
Now I'm going to have to check that every single time.
Let me, let me explain, let me explain my order here.
Okay.
So Smashing the State Machine, obvious filter chains.
I think there's a big amount of implement, uh, implications to this research with turning LFI to RCE.
Easy peasy.
No, you just eliminated a very strong precondition, a very challenging precondition to go to RCE, um, which is awesome.
Um, teams, I think the, the piece about just going from class name to injection to XSS is just stunning.
Um, so I, I gave him credit for that.
And then also the technical details while we, we didn't really cover them here of that inter-process communication, um, technique that he used there, uh, was, was really, really engaging.
And I think, um, highlights a knowledge of electron internals that, uh, I hadn't really seen showcased elsewhere.
So I, I think that that, that was why I placed that at, at three request smuggling and parser inconsistencies.
So I think that, uh, uh, is very practical and very reproducible in action, you know, actual environments.
Reverse proxies are used everywhere.
Reverse proxies are used to block off endpoints everywhere.
So I think, um, uh, you know, these pieces of research are very applicable.
Cookie crumbles actually put this at six because I think that they're, that cookies are an underserved piece of, uh, sort of browser mechanics.
They were very much focused on, you know, back in the days of like sea surf coming out and that sort of thing.
And, um, you know, even just in like Dom XSS environment, I feel like cookies are just kind of underserved in general.
Um, and so I, I've, I've got some extra love for cookies lately.
Um, Akamai, I put that below to break it out.
Um, mostly because cookie crumbling didn't really seem right at seven.
Uh, and the Akamai one is a little bit less, it's kind of, kind of like a vuln story, less of a, like applicable research that can be used in other environments.
Um, and then I put the EPP stuff there as well, uh, in eight, because once again, it's a vuln story, um, which is very engaging and fascinating.
And I'm so glad I heard the story, but, um, not necessarily reproducible for us in other environments.
And then number nine, we both put SMTP smuggling there because it's not a web vulnerability.
Um, so I think, I think that's kind of where my, my top, top 10 or top nine are.
And I guess, um, lands on the list, uh, pretty different from, from what they actually came up with.
Yeah. I mean, it's super, uh, I read through, I think, I think yours, your, your, your ordering is probably a little more level headed than mine.
I'm like, this is, these are cool bugs.
The more complicated, the better, like, or maybe the more, the more, uh, the more dumb, easy, the better.
I don't know. I, uh, I, I like, there's something about that, like, uh, really easy exploitation aspect that really, uh, is, is so fun.
It's that like, it's just like, oh, wow. This really simple bug is like just out there.
Elegant exploits are, are, are very cool for sure.
Alrighty, man. Is that it for you? We calling it a wrap there?
I think that's it. That's a wrap.
Alright, that's the pod.
That's the pod.
That's the pod. Peace.
Peace.